right now we are awaiting president  Trump's remarks at the salute to service  dinner in West Virginia but first his  EPA Administrator Minister Scott Pruett  is denying reports that he personally  asked the President to fire Attorney  General Jeff Sessions and let him run  the Justice Department Pruett told Fox  News that the story is quote 100% false  however just a short time ago a White  House spokesman told reporters the  president is looking into the reports  that he calls troublesome he added that  the president has been very concerned  about reports of possible ethics  violations by administrator Pruitt